die boeing 314 clipper königin des
atlantiks
in den 30er jahren ist sie das größte
flugzeug ihrer zeit und das erste des
passagiere nonstop von den usa nach
europa bringt ihre ausstattung ist luxus
pur und die bohlen clip aber quasi ein
fliegendes vier sterne hotel
wie sieht es aus wenn sich diese legende
der luftfahrt mit einer flugzeug ikone
von heute misst
der airbus
a350 das modernste und
umweltfreundlichste
langstreckenflugzeug unserer zeit
seine triebwerke gelten als die
effizientesten der welt
[Musik]
in der kabine sorgt hightech für
maximalen komfort
der a350 war ein quantensprung in der
kommerziellen luftfahrt
zwei fliegende giganten drei kategorien
ein spannender vergleich
kategorie 1 konstruktion
welches flugzeug hat die luftfahrt mehr
revolutioniert
kategorie 2 komfort in welchem flugzeug
fliegen die passagiere luxuriöser
und kategorie 3 technik
welches der beiden flugzeuge verfügt
über die innovativen systeme
wir werden es herausfinden
[Applaus]
seattle usa heimat des
flugzeugherstellers boeing
in den fabrikhallen am dummy shriver
entsteht ab 1936 die boeing 314 clipper
ihre ausmaße sind für die damalige zeit
gigantisch das flugzeug ist 32 meter
lang und hat eine spannweite von knapp
47 meter
[Musik]
seine reichweite
5900 kilometer mehr als jedes andere
passagierflugzeug seiner zeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in der kabine ist platz für 74 fluggäste
ende der 30er jahre ein absoluter rekord
[Musik]
die bullen 314 ist eine
ingenieurtechnische meisterleistung
doch wie schlägt sich die flugzeug
legende im vergleich mit einem der
erfolgreichsten hightech flieger der
gegenwart
toulouse frankreich hauptsitz des
flugzeugherstellers airbus und die
geburtsstätte des bisher modernsten
passagierflugzeugs des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
der airbus a 350 eine moderne ikone
in seiner längsten version ist der
flieger rund 74 meter und hat eine
spannweite von 65 metern
diese ultra long range variante schafft
18.000 kilometer am stück mehr als jedes
andere zweistrahlige passagierflugzeug
seine maximal kapazität liegt bei 480
passagieren
der a350 basiert auf den neuesten
erkenntnissen im flugzeugbau
die boeing b 314 und der airbus a350
zwei flugzeug legenden im vergleich los
geht es mit der ersten kategorie
konstruktion unter 1 welches flugzeug
hat das revolutionäre konzept
fliegen ist seit jeher ein
menschheitstraum anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts wird er endgültig realität
als die gebrüder wright 1903 zu ihrem
motorisierten pionier flug abheben
von 20 jahre später beginnt die goldene
ära der luftfahrt- der technische
fortschritt ermöglicht erstmals den bau
von passagierflugzeugen
das große ziel der fluggesellschaften
ist es eine nonstop transatlantik
verbindungen anzubieten
denn sie verspricht ein großes geschäft
jede fluggesellschaft wollte sich die
transatlantik route als erste sicher
mitte der 1920 er jahre preisen rund
eine million menschen pro jahr zwischen
amerika und europa hin und her auf dem
seeweg fast jeder fünfte davon ist
erster klasse unterwegs solche
passagiere haben viel geld und wenig
zeit perfekte kunden für teure luxus
flüge die es bislang aber noch nicht
gibt
im februar 1936 schreibt die
amerikanische fluggesellschaft pan
american airways systems kurz panam den
auftrag für ein großflugzeug aus
die anforderungen an das neue flugzeug
waren für damalige zeiten geradezu
utopisch es soll platz bieten für rund
70 passagiere und für viereinhalb tonnen
nutzlast und voll beladen über den
atlantik fliegen können für den besten
entwurf lobt panam eine prämie von
50.000 us dollar aus umgerechnet heute
knapp eine million dollar
unternehmer und flugzeugbauer william
boeing stellt sich der herausforderung
zusammen mit dem jungen ingenieur world
beer
ihr erstes großes problem die start und
landebahnen sind ende der 1930 er jahre
zu kurz für ein flugzeug dieser größe
deshalb beschließen sie ein flugboot zu
entwickeln das braucht zum starten und
landen lediglich eine geschützte bucht
freund flugboot konto fast jede
küstenstadt der welt ansteuern
ihr konzept ein gigantischer
schwimmkörper als rom kombiniert mit den
hightech flügeln eines militärischen
experimentalflugzeug und den neuesten
und leistungsstärksten motoren der
damaligen zeit
das konzept überzeugt im sommer 1936
beginnt boeing mit der arbeit an der b
314 clipper die 1938 als größtes und
leistungsfähigstes passagierflugzeug der
welt ihren jungfernflug absolviert
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg nehmen
reichweite und passagier zahlen
kontinuierlich zu in den 60er jahren
werden flugzeuge schließlich massen
verkehrstauglich die devise der
flugzeugbauer und der airlines lautet
immer schneller und immer größer
höhepunkt dieser entwicklung sind
flugzeuge wie die concorde oder die
boeing 747
heute geht der trend im flugzeugbau
wieder weg davon ziel ist es flugzeuge
mit großer reichweite zu bauen die
gleichzeitig sehr sparsam sind
als die airbus ingenieure 2004 beginnen
ein konzept für einen neuen
langstreckenjet zu erarbeiten haben sie
das klare ziel vor augen in sachen
design und effizienz alle anderen
flugzeuge in den schatten zu stellen
[Musik]
dafür setzen die ingenieure zuerst
einmal bei material an anstatt den rumpf
wie bei vielen flugzeugen in der
vergangenheit üblich aus aluminium und
metall verbundwerkstoffen zu bauen
verwenden sie nun
kohlefaserverbundstoffen kurz cfk
der vorteil ist dass das material leicht
elastisch und extrem stabil ist
um den platz im flugzeug zu maximieren
entscheiden sich die flugzeugbauer für
einen kreisrunden rumpf dadurch sind die
kabinen wende steil und die passagiere
haben mehr platz
[Musik]
auch die triebwerke werden neu
entwickelt speziell angepasst auf die
flugeigenschaften des a350
[Musik]
pro passagier verbraucht der flieger nur
2,9 liter kerosin auf 100 kilometer rund
25 prozent weniger als ältere
flugzeugtypen wie zb der a340
als die airbus ingenieure ihr finales
design vorstellen sind die kunden
begeistert bei produktionsstart fliegen
über 550 bestellungen vor ein voller
erfolg
auf den ersten blick sitzen sowohl die
boeing 314 klippe als auch der a350 in
sachen entwurf neue maßstäbe wobei der
ansatz des flugs noch ein stück
revolutionärer erscheint
nächste runde in der kategorie
konstruktion welcher flieger hat die
bahnbrechende hre bauweise
eine große herausforderung für die
ingenieure der boeing 314 klippe das
flugboot muss nicht nur die
eigenschaften eines flugzeugs besitzen
sondern auch wie ein schiff im wasser
fahren können
der gewaltige rumpf der b 314 ist daher
wie bei einem boot geformt
[Musik]
der rumpf hatte den nachteil dass er
durch seine form nicht so dynamisch war
dazu verpassen die ingenieure dem
flugboot sogenanntes wings kleine
stummel flügel an den seiten des ruhms
sie stabilisieren das flugboot im wasser
und dienen gleichzeitig als
treibstofftanks
[Musik]
um gewicht zu sparen wählen die
ingenieure die ganz metallbau weise
diese technik ist in der zivilen
luftfahrt damals bereits fast 20 jahre
bekannt
1919 absolviert das erste komplett aus
metall gebaute zivile serien flugzeug
seinen jungfernflug die j 13 von hugo
junkers ein passagierflugzeug mit platz
für vier personen
aber das konzept eines ganzmetall
flugzeug setzt sich nur langsam durch
viele konnten sich nicht vorstellen dass
ein flugzeug das aus einem so schweren
material metall gebautes zuverlässig
fliegen kann
für ein flugboot ist die metallbau weise
ideal vor allem im wasser ist metall
deutlich unempfindlicher als holz
das gerüst der boeing clipper besteht
aus spannten eine art querstreben
darüber verlaufen in längsrichtung
sogenannte stringer die für zusätzliche
festigkeit sorgen
angepasst an die innenraum aufteilung
des flugzeuges gibt es weitere streben
und stützen die für noch mehr stabilität
sorgen
insgesamt wiegt das metall skelett des
flugzeugs gerade einmal zwei tonnen ein
absolutes leichtgewicht für damalige
verhältnisse
das gerüst planken die techniker mit
aluminium zehntausende für hand
gesetzten eaton halten das gigantische
flugzeug zusammen dafür dass am rumpf
kein wasser eindringt sorgen zement und
der damals neuartige werkstoffe european
kautschuk besser bekannt als neopren
dann ist es soweit im juni 1939 wird die
clipper in dienst gestellt
auch wenn der erste passagier
linienflugverkehr über den atlantik mit
beginn des zweiten weltkriegs vorerst
wieder endet insgesamt werden zwölf
solcher flug boote für panam gebaut
[Musik]
auch beim bau des a350 setzen die
konstrukteure auf neueste materialien
und fertigungsmethoden
insgesamt 53 prozent des airbus bestehen
aus cfk mehr als bei anderen
vergleichbaren flugzeugtypen
derzeit hält man aufgrund seiner
hightech materialien geht der a350 als
wegweisend in der luftfahrtbranche den
grundstein für das high tech material
liegt der amerikaner thomas alva edison
als er 1879 die glühbirne erfindet davor
hatte er lange nach einem material
gesucht das nicht nur elektrizität
leitet sondern auch robust und zugleich
biegsam ist eine japanische bambus art
deren fasern er durch erhitzen verkohlte
eignete sich schließlich für die
herstellung eines kohle glühfaden
kohlenstofffasern spielen gut 80 jahre
später eine wichtige rolle bei der
herstellung des carbonfaserverstärkten
kunststoffen cfk
forscher entwickeln ihn in den 50er
jahren auf der suche nach leichten und
gleichzeitig robusten materialien auch
für raketenbauer wichtige eigenschaften
bei der herstellung von cfk werden
hardenne lagen von kohlenstofffasern in
eine matrix aus kunstharz eingebettet
der rumpf des a350 wird in drei langen
sektionen gebaut die später
millimetergenaue zusammengesetzt werden
das besondere die sektion bestehen aus
kohlefaser paneelen die zur oberschale
zur unterscheide und zu den beiden
seiten teilen mit den fenstern
zusammengefügt werden
die einzelnen teilstücke sind dabei bis
zu 20 meter lang der vorteil dieser
konstruktionsweise ist die geringe
anzahl an quer nähten und die über das
ganze flugzeug laufenden längst nähte
erhöhen zusätzlich die stabilität des
rumpfes
auch von vorteil ist dass bei einem
schaden nur das betroffene teilstück
ausgetauscht werden muss
neun jahre nach den ersten entwürfen
folgt im juni 2013 endlich die
bewährungsprobe der a350 hebt zum
jungfernflug ab und der ist in jeder
hinsicht ein voller erfolg
[Musik]
ob bei der boeing 314 clipper oder dem
airbus
a350 die ingenieure setzen auf für ihre
zeit hoch moderne konstruktionsmethoden
die die luftfahrt auf ein neues level
heben
runde drei in der kategorie konstruktion
welches flugzeug hat das innovative
tragflächen konzept
bei den flügeln der boeing clipper kommt
die boeing xb 15 ins spiel der bomber
der 1937 seinen erstflug absolviert ist
das größte und schwerste flugzeug das
bis dahin in den usa gebaut wurde es
bleibt nur beim prototyp doch von seiner
entwicklung profitiert später auch die b
17 der bomber der fliegende festung
genannt wurde
die boeing clipper übernimmt das konzept
der gigantischen flügel des xp 15 fast
unverändert die tragflächen haben eine
profil dicke von rund eineinhalb metern
im vergleich zu heutigen flugzeugen
wirken sie zwar wie riesige klötze doch
in den 1930 er jahren war dieses
tragfähigen konzept die einzige
möglichkeit ein flugzeug dieser größe
zum fliegen zu bringen
moderne tragflächen sind elastisch so
dass sie auch bei hoher krafteinwirkung
nicht brechen die tragflügel von damals
waren aus metall und vergleichsweise
steiß
um durch die belastung nicht abzuknicken
brauchten sie einen großen querschnitt
die tragflächen der bohlen clipper waren
sogar so groß dass man über einen
schacht die triebwerke erreichen konnte
ein bahnbrechendes konzept für die
damalige zeit
doch derartige flügel konstruktionen
sind auf dauer nicht aero dynamisch
genug
über die jahrzehnte entwickeln
ingenieure zahlreiche neue immer
effizientere konzepte
[Musik]
heute hat sich eine form weitgehend
durchgesetzt der pfeil flügel
[Musik]
je stärker die pfeilung des flügels ist
desto weniger strömungswiderstand
entsteht an der vorderseite der
tragfläche
die luft kann besser am flügel entlang
strömen und das flugzeug kann schneller
fliegen
[Musik]
beim airbus a350 entscheiden sich die
konstrukteure für eine hohe pfeilung von
35 grad
dadurch besitzt der flieger bei hoher
geschwindigkeit eine besonders gute
aerodynamik und er erreicht eine
reisegeschwindigkeit von über 900
kilometer pro stunde bei niedrigem
spritverbrauch
[Musik]
dass die tragflächen konstruktion ist
ein entscheidender faktor dafür dass der
flieger bis zu 25 prozent weniger
treibstoff braucht verglichen mit
anderen langstreckenflieger
die gebogenen spitzen an den enden der
tragflächen genannt winglets optimieren
den luftstrom das verbessert den
auftrieb und spart sprit
die idee dazu schauten sich flugzeug
ingenieure schon vor einem halben
jahrhundert bei greifvögeln ab die
nutzen ihre gefächerten flügelspitzen um
langsam in der luft gleiten nach beute
ausschau zu halten
die airbus ingenieure perfektionierten
das prinzip beim a350 nach den neuesten
aero dynamischen erkenntnissen
ein weiterer vorteil der winglets ist
dass die flugzeuge dadurch leiser
fliegen
dank der kohlefaser verbundwerkstoffe
sind die flügel besonders elastisch
trotz ihrer ausmaße von 32 metern länge
und sechs metern breite können die
tragflächen des a350 wie die flügel
eines vogels nach oben und nach unten
schwingen und sich so optimal den aero
dynamischen gegebenheiten anpassen
für die passagiere besteht dabei keine
gefahr bei tests wurden die flügel sogar
für mehrere stunden fünf meter nach oben
und nach unten gebogen ohne risse zu
bekommen
auch wenn die tragflächen der boeing 314
durch ihre für damalige verhältnisse
einzigartige größe beeindrucken mit den
hochmodernen tragflächen des a350 können
sie nicht mithalten
fazit in der kategorie konstruktion
die bohnen 314 klippe hat mit
innovativem design die luftfahrt
revolutioniert der airbus a 350 hingegen
überzeugt durch die souveräne umsetzung
heutigen wissens und durch den einsatz
von hightech materialien
wie sieht es aus in der kategorie
komfort
runde eins in welcher der beiden
flugzeug ikonen haben die passagiere
mehr platz und mehr bewegungsfreiheit
[Applaus]
ein flug mit der boeing klippe von
europa nach amerika dauerte bei rund 300
kilometer pro stunde rund 24 stunden die
ticketpreise waren vergleichbar mit
denen einer luxuriösen schiffsreise ein
oneway flug von freund in irland nach
new york kostete damals 375 us-dollar
heute entspricht das ungefähr
7000 dollar
in die b 314 gab es nur eine sitzklasse
nämlich die erste klasse nur reiche
leute konnten sich die tickets leisten
und erwartet einen gewissen luxus
die boeing clipper ist zweistöckig
konstruiert im unteren deck sitzen die
fluggäste gemütlich in abteilen anstatt
wie heute in reihen hintereinander
[Musik]
das passagier deck ist in elf bereiche
unterteilt
5 abteile mit je zehn sitzplätzen dazu
eine bordküche
[Musik]
und ein geräumiger speiseraum und
ein exklusives abteil mit vier
sitzplätzen zwei ankleide räumen mit
toiletten und eine hochzeitssuite
eine hochzeit zu jedem flugzeug das gab
es vorher nie und danach auch nicht mehr
lediglich beim start und bei der landung
müssen die passagiere auf ihren
sitzplätzen bleiben sonst können sie
sich frei bewegen
[Musik]
ein flugerlebnis dass es bis dahin noch
nicht gegeben hat die luxusausstattung
macht die riesigen flug boote weltweit
bekannt kann da ein moderner flieger
überhaupt mithalten
[Musik]
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg ermöglicht
technischer fortschritt den bau von
immer größeren und leistungsstärkeren
flugzeugen
um die maschinen auszulasten und um mehr
kunden zu bekommen übernehmen die
fluggesellschaften das klassen prinzip
von den großen transatlantik schiffen
und erfinden dafür einen neuen namen die
economy class
es war ein voller erfolg die airlines
die economy class anboten hatten
innerhalb von drei monaten fast 30
prozent mehr passagiere
auch heutzutage ist der konkurrenzkampf
zwischen den airlines groß ein flug über
den atlantik dauert nur noch rund
sechseinhalb stunden
gleichzeitig wollen die meisten
passagiere aber so wenig wie möglich
zahlen eine weitere herausforderung beim
a350
größtmögliche bewegungsfreiheit für
fluggäste zu schaffen bei gleichzeitig
maximaler auslastung der maschine um das
zu erreichen setzen die ingenieure auf
ein ganzes paket an neuerungen
durch die runde form des rumpfes sind
die seitenwände im passagierbereich
nahezu senkrecht
das ermöglicht die nutzung der vollen
kabinen breite von fünf metern 61
bei neun sitzen pro reihe bleiben jedem
passagier 48 cm raum kein vergleich zum
legendären konkurrenten aber etwas mehr
als in den meisten anderen modernen
passagierfliegern
der kohlefaser verbundstoff cfk macht
einen weiteren komfort faktor möglich
seine festigkeit hat es den ingenieuren
erlaubt die fenster um gut ein drittel
größer zu bauen verglichen mit anderen
modernen flugzeugtypen
durch die riesigen fenster wirkt die
kabine optisch größer das vermittelt ein
angenehmes raumgefühl
mit solchen kniffen gelingt es den
flugzeugbauern dass die passagiere im
a350 für heutige verhältnisse ein gefühl
von platz haben
[Musik]
dennoch kein vergleich zu damals gegen
das platzangebot und die
bewegungsfreiheit in der b 314 clipper
hat der a350 keine chance
runde zwei in der kategorie komfort
welches flugzeug hat das überzeugendere
bord angebot
eines der absoluten highlights an bord
der klippe ist die art wie für das
kulinarische wohl der gäste gesorgt wird
statt wie heute vom tablett am platz zu
essen begibt man sich an bord der b 314
in den speisesaal
in kleinen gruppen bekommen die
fluggäste dort ein sechs gänge menü
serviert vorbereitet von sterneköchen
und dann an bord von stewart zubereitet
und serviert
tape und die tische waren mit
tischtüchern gedeckt und man es von
porzellantellern
bord kino gibt es noch nicht obwohl
hollywood boomt ende 1937 einige monate
vor dem jungfernflug der klippe hat
disneys blockbuster schneewittchen und
die sieben zwerge premiere
erste reguläre filmvorführungen in
flugzeugen gibt es erst seit 1961
in der b 314 vertreiben sich die
passagiere die zeit mit gemütlichem
philosophieren lesen karten und
gesellschaftsspiele
und wenn sie einmal ein dringendes
bedürfnis haben begeben sie sich in die
großzügig bemessenen badezimmer
inklusive warmen wasser
[Musik]
dieses wird über ein ausgeklügeltes
heizsystem gewonnen die hydraulikpumpe
eines der vier flugmotoren punkt glykol
in einen boiler
dieser boiler ist mit abgas rohren
hinter dem motor verbunden
die abgase erhitzen das glück wohl dass
von dort zu einem weiteren boiler fließt
und da das wasser erwärmt
das heiße wasser fließt dann über ein
leitungssystem zu den toiletten und in
die bordküche
das warme wasser an bord war das
i-tüpfelchen der luxusausstattung
dank ihres damals einzigartigen bord
angebots nennt man die klippe auch ein
fliegendes hotel eigentlich unschlagbar
obwohl
auch in einem a350 ist es das ziel die
fluggäste auf den bis zu 19 stündigen
flügen bestens zu unterhalten
und das geht am besten mit dem board
entertainment system für filme serien
und spiele gibt es ein 11,6 zoll display
in full hd darauf können via usb auch
mitgebrachte filme laufen in demmin
temps am entwischen kann man sich bei
einigen fluggesellschaften sogar das
board entertainmentprogramm im voraus
über eine app zusammenstellen
außerdem ist im a350 standardmäßig wlan
verfügbar dank einer extra starken
antenne in einer kuppel auf dem rumpf
in über 3.000 metern höhe verbinden sich
die server in den flugzeugen mit
satelliten diese tauschen wiederum ihre
signale mit bodenstationen aus die mit
dem internet verbunden sind
so können passagiere darin surfen
[Musik]
platz für einen speisesaal ist bei den
heutigen passagier massen aber selbst im
modernsten flieger nicht drin die
mittlerweile üblich heißt es hier
vorgekochte portionen in den dampfgarer
schieben und fertig
in sachen geschmack sind die airlines
selbst gefragt so testen einige zum
beispiel die gerichte in einer
kompression kammer die die bedingungen
während eines fluges simuliert denn bei
niedrigerem druck schmeckt und riecht
man schlechter ähnlich wie bei einer
erkältung
deswegen müssen die gerichte stärker
gewürzt sein
[Musik]
fazit auch wenn das entertainment in
einem a350 viel hermacht in sachen bord
angebot vor allem beim essen kann die
moderne maschine mit der b 314 klippe
bei weitem nicht mithalten
letzter punkt in der kategorie komfort
welcher flieger hat die besseren
features
eine absolute besonderheit an bord der
boeing clipper ist es dass sich die
abteile zu schlafkojen umbauen lassen
natürlich mussten die gäste das nicht
selbst machen dass der aufgabe des teams
das prinzip haben sich die ingenieure
bei den schlafwagen der bahn abgeschaut
wo sich zwei zusammengeschobene sitze in
ein bett verwandeln lassen
zusätzlich gibt es noch herunter
klappbare liegen so dass eine art
hochbett entsteht vorhänge sorgen dazu
für größtmögliche privatsphäre
allerdings gibt es an bord der klipper
nur 36 schlafplätze deswegen sind die
maschinen die eigentlich platz für 74
passagiere haben auf den atlantik flügen
immer nur halb ausgebucht denn jeder
fluggast will eine schlafkoje haben
[Musik]
dank ihres luxus und ihrer einzigartigen
ausstattung wird die b 314 clipper sogar
zum ersten präsidenten flugzeug der welt
1943 reist franklin d roosevelt damals
staatsoberhaupt der usa in einem der
legendären flug boote zur casablanca
konferenz nach marokko einem
geheimtreffen der anti-hitler-koalition
im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert sieht
das anders aus kein wunder schließlich
entfallen bei modernen flugzeugen wie
dem a350 im schnitt rund 71 prozent der
plätze auf die economy class
ausgestreckt schlafen
davon können die passagiere dort nur
träumen mehr als den sitz ein paar
zentimeter nach hinten zu kippen ist
nicht möglich die einzige chance hier zu
punkten ist erneut mit hightech
wie zum beispiel mit dem sogenannten
mood lighting system die kabinen
beleuchtung kann über 16 millionen
verschiedene farbtöne erzeugen und so
unterschiedliche lichtstimmungen
simulieren sonnenauf- und -untergang
inklusive das hält den biorhythmus der
passagiere möglichst im gleichgewicht
und reduziert den jetlag
ein zweiter entscheidender faktor dass
die passagiere ausgeruht aus dem flieger
steigen ist die kabinen belüftung
alle zwei bis drei minuten wird die luft
im a350 erneuert dafür wird via
kompressor der triebwerke luft
eingesaugt die sogenannte zapft ist bis
zu 200 grad heiß da die ozonwerte in
großer höhe recht hoch sind wird das
ozon herausgefiltert die luft herunter
gekühlt und mit bereinigter kabinenluft
vermischt die reinigungs filter sind
dieselben wie sie in op-sälen zum
einsatz kommen
außerdem ist die kabinenluft 15%
feuchter als in anderen flieger dadurch
trocknen die schleimhäute nicht so stark
aus und man fühlt sich fit
hier ganz anders als aluminium rostet
cfk nicht und hält die höhere
luftfeuchtigkeit problem
dank künstlicher sonnenaufgänge und
einer hochmodernen
belüftungsanlage kommen im a350 auch die
passagiere der economy class recht
ausgeruht ans ziel im direkten vergleich
hat das flugboot mit seinen betten aber
trotzdem die nase vorne zeit für das
fazit in der kategorie komfort
und das ist ziemlich eindeutig trotz
hightech gegen den luxus der boeing 314
clipper hat der airbus a350 in sachen
komfort kaum eine chance
[Musik]
und nun zur dritten kategorie im duell
der flugzeug giganten technik
erstens welche der beiden flughäfen hat
die besseren flug steuerungs und
navigationssysteme um das gigantische
flugboot sicher über den atlantik zu
navigieren braucht es ein team von
mindestens fünf mann drei piloten einen
navigator und einen funker
die crew mitglieder haben nautische
ränge panam präsident horrortrip
bezeichnete seine flug boote als klippe
nach dem vorbild der berühmten clipper
schiffe die im neunzehnten jahrhundert
fracht und passagiere über den atlantik
transportierten und
das maritime flair zu verstärkten tragen
die besatzungen marine blaue uniformen
und werden als kapitän erster offizier
oder stuart bezeichnet
titel die sich bis heute in der
fliegerei gehalten haben
ganz vorne im flugzeug sitzen die
piloten der kapitän und einer seiner
beiden offiziere ihr job ist es das
flugzeug zu steuern der funker ist für
den kontakt mit den bodenstationen
zuständig sprechfunk funktioniert zu
dieser zeit nur über sehr geringe
reichweiten deshalb kommuniziert man
über morsezeichen
besonders wichtig ist das einholen der
aktuellen wetterberichte denn bei der
maximalen flughöhe von 3000 metern ist
das flugboot und wettern viel stärker
ausgesetzt als heutige flugzeuge die
fast dreimal so hoch fliegen
die navigation an bord funktionierte wie
auf einem schiff die angaben für die
richtung kommen vom navigator
gps und radar sind noch nicht erfunden
er navigiert mit hilfe von karten und
einem sextanten
anfang des achtzehnten jahrhunderts
revolutionierte der sextant die
positionsbestimmung auf hoher see und
ermöglichte entdeckern wie thomas james
cook spektakuläre forschungsreisen
mit dem sextanten mister navigator den
winkel zwischen dem horizont und den
gestirnen wie dem mond den sternen und
der sonne
gleichzeitig bestimmt er die uhrzeit und
gleicht die daten mit einer code tabelle
ab daraus ergibt sich die position des
flugzeuges
dafür gibt es an bord der klippe eine
glaskuppel das sogenannte astronom es
ermöglicht einen rundum blick in den
himmel
das größte problem war dass die b 314 in
nur 3000 metern höhe flog also unter der
wolken höhe wenn man pech hatte war der
himmel den flug über bewölkt und man
konnte keine sterne sehen
bei schlechter sicht helfen die
navigatoren kleine fähnchen die an den
flügelenden angebracht sind sie zeigen
ihnen wie stark der seitenwind ist so
können die navigatoren kalkulieren wie
sehr die piloten gegensteuern müssen um
auf kurs zu bleiben
[Musik]
dank ausgeklügelter navigations
techniken bringen die flight groß die
flugroute selbst bei widrigen umständen
sicher ans ziel
beim a350 braucht es inzwischen nur noch
pilot und kopilot den rest übernehmen
computer
neben den heute standardmäßigen systemen
wie dem autopiloten hat airbus a350
weitere instrumente verbaut die das
fliegen noch sicherer und effizienter
machen sollen
das cockpit des a350 zählt zu den
modernsten der welt eines dieser
instrumente ist das automatische
wetterradar während piloten in anderen
flugzeugtypen immer wieder das
wetterradar schicken müssen meldet es im
a350 von sich aus neue unwetter auf der
geplanten route so können piloten
rechtzeitig einen ausweich kurs wählen
ein weiteres system ist das sogenannte
wie tv break away kate vor dem
landeanflug geben die piloten in das
system ein an welchem rollweg sie die
piste wieder verlassen wollen das btv
bremsten das flugzeug genau nach diesen
angaben ab
solche assistenzsysteme bringen
zusätzliche sicherheit und minimieren
die abnutzung des flugzeugs
außerdem haben die piloten sogenannte
head up displays auf halb durchlässigen
herunter klappbaren spiegeln sehen sie
wichtige flugdaten wie zum beispiel die
horizontlinie den kurs die höhe und die
geschwindigkeit
so können sie die umgebung ständig im
blick behalten für die zukunft plant der
flugzeughersteller sogar dass der a350
komplett selbstständig startet und
landet erste tests waren bereits
erfolgreich mehr hightech geht kaum
das fazit trotz ausgeklügelter
navigations techniken bei der b 314
clipper hat diesmal der a350 die nase
vorne nächste runde in sachen technik
welches flugzeug hat die für seine zeit
effizientere triebwerke
als die boeing ingenieure die b 314
planen ist ihnen klar und das
gigantische flugboot in die luft zu
bringen braucht es stärkere motoren als
alle bisher verfügbaren die wahl fällt
auf eine neuentwicklung der firma
rothkötter den flug motorrad r 2600
weil diese motoren hatte wright curtis
zusammen mit dem us militär entwickelt
der motor hat 14 zylinder mit jeweils
rund 30 litern hubraum und bringt es auf
stolze
1600 ps zum vergleich autos aus dieser
zeit haben durchschnittlich gerade
einmal 30 bis 50 ps
in einer boeing clipper sind vier der
neuen leistungsstarken flugmotoren
verbaut sie treiben jeweils einen stahl
propeller mit viereinhalb metern
durchmesser an dank der starken motoren
schafft die boeing 314 eine
höchstgeschwindigkeit von 320 kilometer
pro stunde
die leistung der motoren war so stark
dass das flugzeug im notfall auch mit
nur drei motoren fliegen konnte aber die
motoren müssen permanent überwacht
werden deshalb ist auf jedem flug
mindestens ein ingenieur an bord er kann
jeden motor über ein panel einzeln
ansteuern droht einer zu überhitzen
führte ingenieur über eine außenklasse
mehr luft zu und kühlt den betroffenen
motor gezielt runter
über einen gang in den riesigen flügeln
kann der bord ingenieur sogar während
des fluges die motoren erreichen und
reparaturen vornehmen
[Musik]
dank ihrer extrem starken motoren ist
die boeing clipper das schnellste und
zuverlässigste
passagierflugzeug ihrer zeit
[Musik]
doch auch dem propellerantrieb der
klippe sind grenzen gesetzt
das problem ist wenn sich die propeller
zu schnell drehen reist der luftstrom ab
und sie werden ineffiziente
dadurch ist die geschwindigkeit solcher
flugzeuge begrenzt für ein
passagierflugzeug kein problem doch das
militär fordert schnellere fieger ende
der 1930 er jahre beginnen deshalb der
engländer frank whittle und der deutsche
hans pabst von ohain unabhängig
voneinander an einer neuen antriebsart
zu forschen dem strahl triebwerk auch
düsentriebwerk genannt
ab 1942 fliegen die ersten serienmäßigen
flugzeuge mit düsenantrieb
zunächst nur militärflugzeuge wie die
messerschmitt me 262
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg nutzt auch
die zivile luftfahrt die neuen
triebwerke die im laufe der zeit
weiterentwickelt werden heutige
flugzeugtriebwerke
sogenannte mantel strom oder turbofan
triebwerk sind spritsparender und leiser
die triebwerke des a350 wurden speziell
für das neue flugzeug entwickelt von
zählen zu den effizientesten und
leisesten der welt
[Musik]
kerosin ist heutzutage der größte
kostenfaktor einer airline dazu kommt
dass flughafengebühren inzwischen oft
nach dem lärmpegel eines fliegers
berechnet werden das macht die
triebwerke zu einem entscheidenden
kostenfaktor bei einem flugzeug
neun jahre hat der hersteller rolls
royce an der entwicklung des neuen
triebwerks trent xwb gearbeitet
es hat einen durchmesser von drei metern
und liefert umgerechnet mehr als 50.000
ps2 dieser triebwerke sind im a350
verbaut der propeller am einlass der
turbine der sogenannte fan besteht aus
22 holen titan schaufeln pro sekunde
sagt er mehr als eine tonne luft ein
damit könnte man in zwei minuten eingang
zum stadion mit luft füllen
im inneren des triebwerks teilt sich die
eingesetzte luft in zwei ströme der
innere luftstrom wird verdichtet strömt
in die brennkammer und wird dort mit
kerosin vermischt und verbrannt der
heiße luft strom breitet sich schnell
aus und treibt mehrere turbinen stufen
an ein drei wellen prinzip sorgt hierbei
für optimale drehzahlen der äußere
luftstrom der beim trent xwb rund 90
prozent ausmacht wird um das kern
triebwerk herum geleitet und in der
schub diese beschleunigt diese kalte
luftmasse liefert einen großteil der
schubkraft das macht das triebwerk rund
15 prozent effizienter und leiser als
alle anderen
dank der neu designten triebwerke
schafft der a350 eine
höchstgeschwindigkeit von
960 kilometer pro stunde bei
gleichzeitig niedrigem verbrauch
fazit sowohl der
a350 als auch die b 314 clipper warten
mit den stärksten und leistungsfähigsten
triebwerken ihrer zeit auf
zeit für den allerletzten vergleich
welches flugzeug ist sicherer
während boeing 1937 mitten im bau des
neuen flugboot assist ereignet sich in
new jersey eine der größten
luftfahrtkatastrophe der damaligen zeit
der absturz des luftschiffes hindenburg
bei der landung entzündet sich ein
wasserstofftank der zeppelin stürzt
unkontrolliert zu boden und geht in
flammen auf
[Musik]
der absturz der hindenburg hat die ganze
welt schockiert bis heute ist die
ursache dafür nicht endgültig geklärt
alarmiert durch das unglück bemühen sich
die boeing ingenieure noch mehr die b
314 so sicher wie möglich zu machen
für den fall dass die clipper beim start
oder bei der landung mit einem hindernis
kollidiert ist der untere rumpfbereich
wie bei einem schiff als doppelboden
gebaut
dieser wiederum ist in zehn getrennte
zellen unterteilt wasserdichte schotten
sollen verhindern dass bei einem schaden
das gesamte flugzeug voll wasser läuft
und sinkt
[Musik]
zusätzlich sind an jedem quer schott
zwei pumpen installiert um im
schadensfall das eindringende wasser so
schnell wie möglich wieder loszuwerden
[Musik]
diese als bootsrumpf konstruierte untere
rumpfbereich macht das flugboot bei
einer notlandung im wasser so gut wie
unsinkbar
rosi entziehen die am ende des zweiten
weltkriegs eine bei einem manöver
beschädigte clipper versenken wollte
braucht es rund 1300 schuss bis sie
unterging
für den fall einer notlandung im wasser
hat jeder passagier eine schwimmweste
unter seinem sitz zusätzlich gibt es
acht rettungsboote als notausstieg
dienen die fenster der passagier abteile
sie liegen nahe über der
wasseroberfläche günstig für den fall
eines notausstieg
zusätzlich sind alle im flugzeug
verbauten materialien feuerfest
egal ob sitze teppiche oder tischdecken
jedes teil wurde von einem speziellen
institut auf feuerfestigkeit getestet
die maßnahmen zahlen sich aus die boeing
314 clipper ist das sicherste flugzeug
seiner zeit
nur einmal kommt es zu einem schweren
crash bei einer missglückten landung
auch beim a350 haben die ingenieure
alles gegeben um das flugzeug sicher zu
machen
um die neuen materialien die beim a350
verbaut sind auf herz und nieren zu
testen müssen die prototypen zahlreiche
extrem tests überstehen
bei solchen testet man flugzeuge
belastungen aus die um ein vielfaches
höher sind als beim normalen flugbetrieb
zu den härtesten tests gehören die kälte
test dafür begeben sich die ingenieure
nach norwegen um zu untersuchen wie sich
der a350 bei temperaturen bei bis zu
minus 40 grad verhält und bei
probeflügen bringen testpiloten das
flugzeug mit extremen manövern an seine
grenzen
außerdem haben sie getestet wie lange
der flieger mit nur einem triebwerk in
der luft bleiben kann das ergebnis
stolze sieben stunden
damit ist auf allen regulären routen der
welt sichergestellt dass der a350 einen
flugplatz erreichen kann sollte ein
triebwerk ausfallen für den fall einer
evakuierung hat der a350 auf jeder seite
4 notausgänge vorne direkt hinter dem
cockpit vor und hinter dem flügel und am
ende des flugzeugs die besonderheit auf
jeder seite haben drei der vier
notausgänge sogar eine doppelte
evakuierungs rutsche so können die
passagiere das flugzeug im notfall noch
schneller verlassen der a350 gehört zu
den neuen flugzeugtypen die seit 1959
noch nie abgestürzt sind in sachen
sicherheit haben sowohl die klippe wie
auch der a350 extrem hohe standards bei
einer notlandung im wasser wäre man im
legendären flugboot sogar besser
aufgehoben das ergebnis der kategorie
technik bei flug systemen und der
effizienz des antriebs hat die moderne
ikone die nase vorne in puncto
sicherheit kann die propeller betriebene
legende aber auf jeden fall mithalten
sie sind beide meilensteine der
luftfahrtgeschichte
die boeing 314 das größte und
leistungsfähigste passagierflugzeug
seiner zeit
und der
a350 das derzeit modernste und
umweltfreundlichste
langstreckenflugzeug
egal ob in sachen konstruktion
luxus oder technik sowohl die boeing 314
klippe als auch der airbus
a350 haben neue maßstäbe im flugzeugbau
gesetzt
[Musik]